hasta el momento se ha confirmado ya por
parte del subsecretario de seguridad
Federal Ricardo Mejía verdeja así como
por la fiscal del Estado de Guerrero
Sandra luz valdovinos que la cifra de
Muertos tras este ataque es ya de 20
personas 20 personas que perdieron la
vida dos heridos y entre los fallecidos
está efectivamente el alcalde de San
Miguel totolapan Conrado Mendoza así
como el padre de este Juan Mendoza quien
también ha gobernado ese municipio entre
otros funcionarios como el director de
seguridad municipal el subsecretario de
seguridad e informó que pues se trata de
posiblemente una disputa de grupos
criminales que operan en la entidad
habló de el grupo de La Familia
Michoacana que es el que domina
actualmente y el resurgimiento de otro
grupo denominado Los Tequileros Que
tenía cuatro años que se creía
extinguido en esa zona de la Tierra
Caliente del Estado de Guerrero y que al
parecer de nueva cuenta irrumpió en la
escena pública y está provocando este
este hecho violento
están Ya desplegados pues los cuerpos de
seguridad del ejército la guardia
nacional decir que tardó ayer mucho
tiempo en llegar a la seguridad de la
zona porque hubo un bloqueo carretero
por parte presumiblemente de estos
mismos grupos criminales precisamente
para impedir que llegara El auxilio es
lo que se sabe hasta el momento la
investigación está abierta qué dijo
Mario el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador al respecto
bueno el presidente lamentó los hechos
desde luego condenó y señaló que esto es
parte de una descomposición que viene de
la mano de la política neoliberal que se
aplicó en secciones anteriores justificó
que estas organizaciones criminales
vienen de tiempo atrás que no surgieron
en este sexenio y defendió de nueva
cuenta su política de seguridad A pesar
de las críticas dice que su gobierno
Está tratando de atender las causas que
generan la violencia y la descomposición
social y que aunque se burla en sus
adversarios es la estrategia que él
seguirá llevando a cabo también ha
reaccionado la gobernadora también del
partido Morena la gobernadora de
Guerrero Evelyn Salgado quien ha
asegurado que no habrá impunidad tras
estos hechos y que se están investigando
para dar con los responsables Lo cierto
es que pues hay mucho cuestionamiento
también el partido de la Revolución
democrática donde pertenecía al alcalde
a cuestionado ya son 18 alcaldes los que
han perdido la vida en este sexenio por
ataques